Traduttore: TEDx Milano Translators
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Allora, voglio partire con una domanda,
e vi chiedo di rispondere di pancia.
Se vi chiedo come va il mondo oggi,
bene o male, per alzata di mano,
chi pensa che vada bene?
Ok.
Abbassate le mani.
Chi pensa che il mondo vada male?
Ok, fate un po' i conti voi.
Questo grafico l'ha fatto Hans Rosling,
un geniale scienziato svedese,
forse l'avete già visto.
E ci fa vedere cosa è successo
negli ultimi 218 anni.
Nel 1800, ciascuno di questi pallini
rappresenta un paese della terra,
e vedete in verticale
l'aspettativa di vita.
In orizzontale vedete il reddito.
Il puntino più avanzato giallo,
piccolissimo, è l'Inghilterra nel 1800.
Aspettativa di vita; 40 anni;
reddito medio equivalente
a quello di oggi: 2500 euro.
Guardate cosa è successo
negli ultimi 200 anni.
Ecco, vedete? Durante l'800
non succede quasi niente.
Il reddito un po' aumenta,
però l'aspettativa di vita
è sempre bassissima.
Guardate cosa succede
al volgere del secolo.
Vedete il buco,
nella Prima Guerra Mondiale?
Si è ripreso subito.
Vedete la Seconda Guerra Mondiale?
Adesso guardate cosa succede
dal dopoguerra in poi,
questa accelerazione,
questa spinta straordinaria.
Vedete, è proprio una trasformazione
della nostra società.
Tutta la popolazione,
tutti i paesi della terra
che raggiungono un livello di benessere,
di aspettativa di vita
assolutamente straordinari.
Ecco, c'è una spinta,
un motore straordinario
che ha reso possibile questo,
ed è la tecnologia.
E c’è un ramo, il braccio operativo
della tecnologia, il business:
attraverso le aziende,
le attività imprenditoriali,
noi siamo riusciti a trasformare
la condizione umana
in una maniera straordinaria.
E quindi oggi ci sono tutta una serie
di indicatori che vedete qui:
da povertà, educazione, alfabetizzazione,
democrazia, vaccinazione,
mortalità infantile.
Tutti questi indici
sono straordinariamente positivi
come non avremmo mai immaginato
qualche decennio fa.
Allo stesso tempo però vi chiedo
di proiettarvi un po' nel futuro.
Allora vi faccio un'altra domanda.
Quando pensiamo al futuro
ci sembra distante...
Chiedo, quanti di voi in questa sala
avete figli, per alzata di mano?
Ok, una buona metà.
Provate a pensare in che anno
avranno la vostra età di oggi.
Oppure, se non avete figli,
i bambini che nascono nel 2018,
in che anno avranno la vostra età di oggi.
Ecco, nel mio caso arrivo al 2051 e 2055.
Quindi pensate cosa è successo
nei precedenti 200 anni,
[e] immaginate, con questa
accelerazione straordinaria,
cosa può succedere
nei prossimi 20, 30, 40 anni.
Pensando che noi
stiamo vivendo delle dinamiche
che non sono lineari,
ma sono esponenziali.
Esponenziale vuol dire
che per un sacco di tempo
non succede nulla,
e poi una specie di esplosione.
E vedete, quando sono nato io
c’erano meno di quattro miliardi
di persone sulla terra.
Adesso ce ne sono quasi 8 miliardi.
Vi rendete conto che viviamo
un'epoca di disruption,
di accelerazione inimmaginabile
di tutta una serie di aspetti,
tutta una serie di trend
sia positivi che negativi.
E infatti la stessa dinamica
la troviamo praticamente ovunque.
Ci sono centinaia di parametri,
d’indicatori, di attività,
e i relativi impatti
che seguono lo stesso tipo di andamento.
Quindi per un sacco di tempo
sembra non succeda niente,
poi ho questa esplosione.
Noi siamo nel mezzo di questa esplosione.
E allo stesso tempo viviamo su un pianeta
che è sempre lo stesso
da miliardi di anni.
Una volta c’era tanto pianeta
e poche persone,
adesso ci sono tantissime persone
e il pianeta è sempre quello.
E abbiamo adottato un modello economico
che poi ha delle conseguenze.
Che ci ha portato
al successo fino ad oggi,
ma non è lo stesso modello
che ci traghetterà
verso un futuro che sia desiderabile.
E quindi vi faccio vedere
cosa sta succedendo oggi
nel mezzo del Pacifico,
nell'atollo delle Midway.
Guardate queste immagini.
Questo è quello che succede
quando noi adottiamo
un modello di business
che funziona fino a un certo punto,
ma non è lo stesso
che ci può portare nel futuro.
Noi vediamo cosa sta succedendo
agli animali, agli Albatros nelle Midway;
ma in realtà la stessa cosa
sta succedendo a noi come esseri umani.
Quindi, se noi guardiamo questa immagine,
e pensiamo all'allattamento,
oggi ci sono,
in alcune zone del pianeta,
quelle più inquinate,
ci sono centinaia, migliaia
di sostanze chimiche tossiche
che sono riscontrabili nel latte materno.
Il latte materno dovrebbe essere trattato
come un rifiuto tossico.
Questo, senza andare tanto in là,
anche nelle zone
più inquinate dell'Italia,
per non parlare poi della Cina
o altre regioni del pianeta.
È chiaro che dobbiamo completamente
trasformare il nostro modello economico.
Dobbiamo trasformare i nostri paradigmi.
E l’altra riflessione
che voglio fare con voi è questa.
Vedete questa linea rossa?
800 metri, il Parco Sempione,
proprio qua a due passi.
Se noi consideriamo
un corpo umano come volume,
sono circa 70 litri.
Tutta l'umanità, tutta la specie umana,
può essere contenuta dentro un cubo
di 800 X 800 X 800 metri.
Il volume di tutti
gli esseri umani oggi sulla Terra.
E allo stesso tempo,
questo puntino microscopico,
questo pixel rispetto
alle dimensioni del pianeta,
usando la tecnologia
e usando i nostri modelli di business,
riesce a impattare il funzionamento
dell'intero pianeta.
Vi rendete conto
che la velocità non è lineare,
il futuro non sarà una proiezione
di quello che abbiamo vissuto nel passato.
Nel futuro vedremo
un'accelerazione drastica
di tutta una serie di fenomeni.
E vedete, questa ruota rappresenta
tutti i paesi della Terra,
e queste barre che si muovono
sono le temperature misurate medie
rispetto allo zero storico.
Guardate cosa succede dal 2000 in poi.
Ovviamente, più diventa rosso,
più il pianeta si sta scaldando.
E vedete la non linearità
di questi cambiamenti?
Vedete il senso di urgenza
che ci porta a cambiare?
Quello che è successo,
praticamente dal 2000 in poi,
è che gli oceani hanno esaurito
la loro capacità
di assorbire il calore,
le emissioni in eccesso.
E quindi la Terra, invece di continuare
ad assorbire i nostri impatti,
comincia a diventare una emettitrice.
Comincia a non essere più in grado
di reggere il nostro impatto.
Quindi dobbiamo passare
da un modello che è estrattivo -
non intendo legato
all'industria mineraria.
Intendo un modello di business
che è guidato da un unico obiettivo:
guardare dove sia il valore,
raccoglierlo e concentrarlo;
estrarlo e concentrarlo;
estrarlo e concentrarlo.
Perché questa macchina straordinaria
che è il business, che è l'azienda oggi,
se guardiamo il modello dominante,
è guidato da un unico obiettivo:
distribuire dividendi agli azionisti,
o massimizzare il valore degli azionisti.
Quindi se c'è questo unico obiettivo,
vuol dire una cosa molto semplice,
ma quasi scioccante:
le persone e il pianeta
non rientrano negli obiettivi di business.
Vi rendete conto
che se ha funzionato fino ad oggi,
nella condizione e con la velocità
di cambiamento che stiamo vivendo,
non potrà funzionare nel futuro.
È fondamentale cambiare.
E per dare un'idea di quanto bene
funzioni questo modello,
vi faccio vedere questa equazione.
Sembra un po' strana: 8 = 4.000.000.000.
Questo modello di concentrazione di valore
funziona talmente bene
che oggi 8 esseri umani sulla Terra,
tanti quanti possono stare
su questo carrello da golf,
hanno la stessa ricchezza
dei 4 miliardi di persone
più povere sul pianeta.
Quindi il business
è una forza straordinaria,
come lo sono i terremoti,
come lo sono i vulcani,
come lo sono gli eventi climatici.
Però è giunto il momento
di trasformarlo nella sua essenza.
È giunto il momento di trasformarlo
in qualcosa che invece
di essere estrattivo è rigenerativo,
qualcosa che riconosce l'interdipendenza
con tutti gli attori,
con tutto il sistema di cui è parte.
Vi faccio leggere questa frase:
“Ogni azienda deve servire
uno scopo sociale.
Deve produrre risultati
non solo finanziari
ma anche beneficiare
tutti i portatori di interesse:
azionisti, dipendenti,
clienti e comunità in cui operano”.
Ecco, quando l'ho vista la prima volta,
ho pensato l'avesse scritta -
non so, Adriano Olivetti,
qualche imprenditore veramente -
mitologico, quasi.
In realtà, questo è un estratto
della lettera che è stata mandata
all'inizio di quest'anno
da Larry Fink,
l'amministratore delegato
del più grande fondo
d'investimento al mondo,
a tutti gli amministratori delegati
delle aziende in cui il fondo investe.
E Larry Fink dice,
a tutte le aziende
in cui il fondo investe -
BlackRock gestisce quasi
sette trilioni di patrimonio,
più di 3 volte il PIL dell'Italia -
dice: “qual è la vostra vocazione?.
Dovete mettere la vocazione,
dovete avere un significato,
dovete avere un ruolo
per impattare positivamente il pianeta”.
Quello che lui dice è,
se voi non considerate questa vocazione,
avrete dei ritorni-
sarete meno profitable,
andrete peggio delle altre aziende,
perché non siete adatti alle sfide
che dobbiamo affrontare collettivamente.
Ecco, in questo contesto
nascono le Benefit Corporation.
Le Benefit Corporation
rappresentano l'evoluzione,
forse la rappresentazione più spinta
di quello che è un business sostenibile:
il concetto di usare il business
come forza positiva.
Come possiamo usare
questa straordinaria potenzialità
per contribuire a risolvere
le grandi sfide del nostro tempo?
Quindi qualsiasi azienda può cominciare
a reinterpretarsi e reinventarsi
in questa direzione,
e quindi può cominciare
a diventare rigenerativa.
Vuol dire che questa azienda
misura quello che conta,
e gestisce tutti i suoi impatti
con la stessa completezza,
con lo stesso rigore
che oggi viene riservato alle misurazioni
di tipo economico-finanziario.
Un'azienda rigenerativa ha una vocazione
che viene scritta nello Statuto.
Negli Stati Uniti esiste
una forma giuridica, già dal 2010,
che riconosce queste aziende,
che non sono for profit,
sono oltre il profit: sono for Benefit.
E hanno la vocazione scritta
nell'oggetto sociale.
Un'azienda rigenerativa compete
non per essere la migliore al mondo,
ma per essere la migliore per il mondo.
E quindi, se noi immaginiamo
che tutte le aziende,
o sempre più aziende,
vadano in questa direzione,
la conseguenza è che usiamo il business
per creare una prosperità durevole,
una prosperità condivisa.
Il pensiero di Kennedy che si avvera.
E quindi qui, ispirandomi
a Carlo Maria Cipolla,
ho provato a rappresentare
in questo grafico
quali sono le principali tipologie
di aziende o di organizzazioni.
Ci sono, diciamo, i "buoni"
che creano un impatto
positivo verso gli altri
e non necessariamente
creano un valore per gli azionisti.
Poi ci sono le locuste,
quelli che distruggono
sia valore per gli altri,
sia valore per sé stessi.
Qui Cipolla in realtà direbbe:
sono gli stupidi,
che fanno un danno agli altri
e fanno un danno anche a sé stessi.
Poi la grande maggioranza delle aziende
sono queste, le estrattive,
che generano un valore per sé stesse,
generano un valore per gli azionisti,
non necessariamente generano
un valore per tutti gli altri.
E infine ci sono le aziende rigenerative,
e quindi le Benefit Corporation
creano un valore tanto per
sé stessi quanto per gli altri.
E quindi questo, se vogliamo,
è un modello già disponibile oggi
che ci auspichiamo
si diffonda il più possibile.
Bob Shiller, Premio Nobel
per l'economia nel 2013,
qualche anno fa disse:
“Credo che le Benefit Corporation
saranno più profittevoli
degli altri tipi di aziende,
proprio perché rispondono
alle esigenze del nostro secolo”.
E queste sono aziende
che usano la tecnologia
per fare una cosa che in passato
non è mai stata possibile:
misurare tutti i propri impatti,
misurare quello che conta
in maniera completa e rigorosa.
E quindi, da una dozzina di anni fa,
è stata creata questa
piattaforma tecnologica,
si chiama B Impact Assessment,
disponibile e accessibile
a chiunque nel mondo,
che consente di capire
se un'azienda sta creando
o distruggendo valore per la società.
Quindi non solo valore economico,
ma anche valore ambientale
e valore sociale.
Quindi oggi è possibile per un'azienda
prendere tutti i propri dati,
misurare tutte le proprie attività
e, usando la tecnologia, fare una cosa
che qualche anno fa non era possibile:
capire se rispetto a questa scala
da 0 a 200 punti
ci troviamo sotto o sopra
questa soglia, diciamo, di equilibrio,
di eccellenza di 80 punti.
Sotto gli 80 punti vuol dire
che è un azienda estrattiva,
che prende dal mondo
più valore di quanto crei.
Sopra gli 80 punti
vuol dire che è rigenerativa,
crea più valore di quanto ne prenda,
e quindi ci auspichiamo
che ce ne siano il più possibile.
Oggi è abbastanza difficile
superare questa soglia.
Quindi vedete,
questo grafico rappresenta-
Nel mondo ci sono più di 70.000 aziende
che si sono misurate
con questo protocollo,
e sono solo 2.650
che superano questa soglia.
Però dimostra una cosa fondamentale:
che è possibile.
Queste sono tutte aziende
che hanno misurato i loro impatti
e, in 60 paesi, 140 industrie diverse
ci dimostrano che è possibile
condurre quasi qualsiasi business
in modo tale da creare più valore
sociale, ambientale, economico
di quanto se ne prenda.
Vi rendete conto di quanto
sia rivoluzionario questo concetto?
Allora nel 2012 cosa abbiamo fatto?
Quando abbiamo fondato Nativa,
abbiamo preso questo modello
dagli Stati Uniti,
abbiamo detto: “se esiste là,
lo possiamo fare anche da noi”.
Abbiamo chiamato avvocati,
abbiamo chiamato notai, giuristi.
Ci siamo messi -
abbiamo scritto uno statuto
in cui scrivevamo che lo scopo di Nativa
era di essere un'azienda rigeneratrice.
Andare oltre questo concetto di profit.
Quindi, fatta l'azienda,
andiamo alla Camera di Commercio.
E cosa succede?
Il nostro statuto viene respinto.
Come viene respinto?
Vi proponiamo una cosa bella,
innovativa, straordinaria.
Già c’è, non chiediamo niente a nessuno.
“No, no, no, non si può fare,
perché la legge proibisce
che una società di capitali
faccia qualcosa di diverso
da produrre valore per gli azionisti”.
Quindi questa cosa non si può fare.
Noi insistiamo,
viene respinto una seconda volta,
viene respinto una terza,
viene respinto una quarta.
La quinta volta, per sfinimento,
l'impiegato della Camera di Commercio
dice, va bene, va bene, dai.
Lo registriamo,
non se ne accorgerà nessuno.
E quindi cominciamo a operare
in questo limbo, in questa area grigia,
speriamo che non se ne accorga nessuno,
e andiamo avanti con le nostre attività.
Questo però, diciamo, non ci va giù.
Allora con Paolo Di Cesare,
co-fondatore di Nativa,
cominciamo ad attivarci,
cominciamo a contattare delle persone
che possono capire l'opportunità,
possono aiutarci a introdurre
questa innovazione.
Creiamo un gruppo di lavoro
che nel giro di 14 mesi,
praticamente scrive un disegno di legge.
Questo disegno di legge
viene presentato al Senato,
viene recepito come emendamento
della legge di stabilità del 2016.
E qua vedete,
il 22 dicembre 2015 la legge passa.
Questo sono io col senatore
Del Barba e Paolo Di Cesare.
E per la prima volta
viene introdotto in Italia
una nuova forma giuridica di impresa
che riconosce le società Benefit,
che sono aziende che "nell'esercizio
delle loro attività economiche,
oltre allo scopo di dividere gli utili,
perseguono una o più finalità
di beneficio comune".
È una riscrittura del DNA delle aziende.
Per cui l'Italia diventa
il primo Stato sovrano al mondo
ad avere questa forma giuridica.
Oggi esiste in 34 stati degli Stati Uniti,
in Italia, in Colombia
e ci sono altri 15 paesi della Terra
che stanno introducendo lo stesso modello.
E quindi l'Italia si ritrova
ad essere il paese al mondo
in cui questo modello
sta crescendo più rapidamente.
Abbiamo più di 85 aziende che superano
questa soglia di 80 punti
misurata, verificata e certificata,
e abbiamo più di 300 aziende
che hanno adottato questa forma giuridica.
Complessivamente, in Europa,
quando è nata Nativa
eravamo il paziente Zero,
non c'era nessuna Benefit Corporation;
oggi, tra Benefit Corporation
e B-Corp certificate
ce ne sono più di 700.
Quindi l'Italia oggi si ritrova a essere
un laboratorio planetario.
Da tutto il mondo ci guardano
e dicono: “Com’è possibile?”.
Vogliamo che questo modello,
questo che state facendo in Italia,
si diffonda anche in altri Paesi.
Quindi crediamo che questo concetto
di azienda rigeneratrice
sia anche molto vicino al nostro DNA,
sia molto vicino al nostro
tessuto imprenditoriale.
E quindi io mi auguro che,
se voi siete cittadini,
cominciate a guardare: quello che comprate,
da dove viene, chi l'ha fatto,
ha un impatto positivo o negativo?
Se siete imprenditori,
la vostra azienda sta creando
o distruggendo valore?
Lo sapete? L'avete mai misurato?
Oggi c'è modo di farlo.
Se siete amministratori,
ci sono decine di città nel mondo oggi -
questo è un esempio
della città di New York -
che stanno adottando questo modello
e lo stanno diffondendo
perché, ovviamente,
più aziende di questo tipo ci sono
in un dato territorio,
meglio è dal punto di vista economico,
dal punto di vista sociale
e dal punto di vista ambientale.
Io sono positivo, ottimista,
nonostante quello che vi ho fatto
vedere all'inizio,
perché credo che i popoli e le nazioni
si comportino saggiamente...
... però dopo aver esaurito
le altre opportunità.
Quindi io non so se abbiamo esaurito
proprio tutte le opportunità.
Credo che questo muro si sta avvicinando
molto più rapidamente
di quanto comunemente si pensi;
ma credo anche che abbiamo
tutte le possibilità, tutti gli strumenti
e ci manca forse solo
un piccolo salto di volontà
per accelerare questa
trasformazione positiva.
Grazie.
(Applausi)